these two glass artists nikolai and
tatyana never expected they would spend
their days fighting russia's justice
system but that's exactly what they have
been doing for the past two years after
their son Julian was arrested and
charged with terrorism together with ten
others he's accused of plotting attacks
during the World Cup and presidential
elections who charges his father called
absurd
they were beating him up to make him say
what was needed but he didn't say
anything then they transferred him to a
different cell with 150 people a bunch
of criminals whose job is to be the
testimony out of someone it's a conveyor
the secret police is in charge every day
people get beaten up with their heads
against the wall beaten with a stick on
their legs heels tailbone and they go
out of there and give any testimony they
need it's a factory lawyers representing
the families have filed the complaints
of torture at the European Court for
Human Rights police denied his claims at
the cordons in Petersburg supporters
call for Julian's freedom the trial is a
rare opportunity for his parents and
wife who he married in prison to see him
Julian and Viktor feeling cuffs are the
last tool to stand trial in the case it
has shocked many around Russia and has
seen sentences of up to 18 years in
prison family and friends of those on
trial say they despite their fears they
will continue to support them and so
have many others around Russia
fabricated cases like this are allegedly
on the rice and rice groups fear that
with Putin's last official years as a
president there will be more repression
Amnesty International says thousands in
Russia have been convicted on fabricated
charges according to the rights group
it's a way for judges and prosecutors to
be promoted and for the country's
leadership to send a stern warning the
truth doesn't really matter all that
matters is the outcome that people have
to be found guilty no matter what they
actually did and their methods for
obtaining this verdict they don't matter
like Nikolay and Tatiana other parents
in the
KACE have campaigned for the release of
their children young men they describe
as nonviolent activists fighting against
what they saw as the rise of nationalism
and fascism he participated in a rally
against animal torture that article is
called this cruel Russian circus they
were demanding not to use animals and
circus and now this article describes
our lives it's the same cruel circus but
with people instead what they do taro
boys has become a circus many fear that
president Putin's planned to give the
constitution priority over international
courts who give them even less
protection against cases like these as
families soon might have nowhere to go
to seek justice step fasten al Jazeera
saint-petersburg